ce soir elles seront les plus belle pour
aller danser séquence de maquillage
appliquée dans les coulisses tout le
monde est en effervescence
au programme deux représentations de
deux heures double stress du coup vu que
c'est le matin et le soir donc on doit
bien tous rappelé avec le public
c'est un peu stressant on stresse mais
on sait qu'on va faire un spectacle et à
la fin comme ça passe vite on est on est
triste que ce soit déjà fini
chants musique
rien n'est laissé au hasard il faut bien
s'échauffer parole de fabrice le
percussionniste du groupe ares lors
venus prêter main forte aux spectacles
le coz et tous ces artistes que nous
voit autour de nous le gros seat une
heure et demie n'a 45 de theix deux
chorégraphies de danse tous alors petits
et grands tout son lumineux dans leurs
costumes réalisés sur mesure sur scène
ils sont plus de 75 à se succéder avec
des tableaux les plus colorés les uns
que les autres et autant de tenues à
professionnels pour ninon même plus
parce qu'il ya des danseurs qui font
deux voire trois danses donc à chaque
fois il y à un échange de costumes de et
de tous les accessoires qui vont avec
donc ça fait beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de choses à fond
dans une fourmilière ça ne s'arrête pas
devant le public comme en coulisses sur
scène dès sa création sont rentrés pour
luna et marine font partie du stade des
mets ta mort en deux heures elle incarne
multitude de personnages là aujourd'hui
c'est le royans donc là j'ai faire
l'oiseau la lionne
je vais faire plusieurs ruelles là pour
commencer je vais faire l'agira c'est
pour ça que je peux encore un billet
puisque les costumes et compliqué à
mettre avec des échasses et de ça et
puis après aussi des buses et des
buffles aussi dans beaucoup d'animaux vu
qu'on est dans le roi lion le cercle de
la vie un hommage au roi lion un
spectacle qui a failli ne pas voir le
jour en raison de la crise sanitaire
alors le jour j sentiment mitigé
mes émotions à son comble du soulagement
de l'effervescence est beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de stress mais avec du plaisir
qu'il a avec ça pas toujours été facile
ce qu'on a eu des moments avec des
couvre-feux donc il a fallu faire venir
les élèves les week-ends les dimanches
et j'avoue que j'ai la chance d'avoir eu
des parents d'élèves qui sont super qui
ont joué le jeu qui ont emmené leurs
enfants
donc c'est pour ça qu'on sait on a pu le
faire parce que on ne s'est pas arrêtée
en fait
[Musique]
le miracle de la vie apprécié à juste
titre par une assemblée conquise
avant un nouveau cycle une nouvelle
année que les élèves et professeurs de
cadence espère moins mouvementée
et